[Music]
tyler is in pennsylvania starting this
hour hey tyler what's up
hey guys how are we doing today better
than i deserve what's up
all right so i'm looking to get some
advice um i'm currently making around 40
000 a year um
and
i don't know what my next move should be
um i pay around 900 for rent um and i
have one kid now and another kid coming
in around this week we're due on the
25th congratulations
thank you thank you my wife is um a
stay-at-home mom
and so you know we're kind of just
working with my income right now um i
have around 5 000 in savings i have my
401k i have stock you know i'm trying to
see what i can do and you know i just
need some guidance in what my next step
should be in housing
you're doing very well congratulations
how old are you thank you
19.
wow
what do you do for a living
so i work i do like sales and food
service it's kind of both um it's kind
of like a convenience store but
a better growth convenience store if
that makes sense you're having baby
number two at 19
yes yes dude my mom gave me a talking to
at 19 before i got a dog she's like i
don't think you're ready for this
you are in it brother so how old were
you when you had the first one
i was 17. wow you're just getting after
it huh so your hands are full okay so um
what is your
35 year old you going to be doing for a
career
oh man i i have dreams of kind of being
retired and uh you know i look to you
dave as you know a huge mentor as i'm a
new listener i don't want you to be
retired at 35. i want you to be making
two million a year what is it you're
going to be doing
um
i don't i don't really know yet um you
know i'm working for a good company i
get you know and there's an e-stop
program i get a a good 401k
um i'm looking to
get into real estate at some point i'm
also really interested into stocks um
you know i have a lot of options due to
me being young but you know i don't
really have a
set journey yet
okay well yeah you you've um
you know in one sense you're 19 and you
shouldn't have all this figured out in
another sense you're making 40 000 and
have two kids so you got to start
figuring it out
you know because here's the thing you uh
you're going to hit what you aim at
and if you aim at nothing
you will hit it every time
right and the chances of you opening
your eyes at 27 making 40 000 for the
same company are strong to quite strong
if you're not headed somewhere yeah
exactly
and so the way we solve your rent
problem
is
in the short term you have to be very
careful and manage and and pick out a
good property and just kind of deal with
life with two kids and super young
marriage and all that and um you'll
laugh about these days later on and go
back in our 23 we were starving to death
but um you know but the but for right
now it's just a pain in the butt
and uh but but the the way you overcome
this is you are aiming at something
further down the road and that will have
so let's just pretend let's pretend that
over the next few months or even years
you decide you want to be doing
something and you just give it a name
whatever the thing is and you're going
to be you know doing real estate and i'm
going to be making 100 000 a year when
i'm 30 years old okay once you start
saying that a lot
and start to believe it and start to
study how what you have to do to make
that come true
uh you know what must be true that is
not true today for me to be there then
immediately you start moving off of the
40 and start moving up
which starts to solve some of the
immediate problems as well and so that's
why i'm asking you all of that instead
of answering your 900 rent question
because
truthfully it's not gonna be easy
to rent a property and feed two kids on
forty thousand dollars
you can do it
but you don't wanna do that for a decade
doing it for 10 months while we're
heading to something else and i'm not
teaching you to be dissatisfied with
your job i'm just saying even if it's
inside this company when you start
talking about the super talk of the
supervisors the managers what about what
do i have to what value can i add to
this organization so that i can move up
because i got two little babies i gotta
feed and i'm trying to be ambitious and
uh wise beyond my ears and show me how
to do that and you'll be when you start
talking that and thinking that and being
that and identifying that that's who you
are that's when the income's gonna start
to change that's why you hear people
calling this show tyler that almost
every single debt-free scream during the
time they were getting out of debt
increase their income
now some of them just did it they took
an extra job pay off debt but some of
them walked into the boss's office and
said what can i do to add value
and the boss goes well you know what i
haven't given you a raise in a while
here's another 20 grand and ding ding
you know it's just stuff like that
happens all the time but it's because
you're paying attention to it
and there's something magical about
sitting down with a supervisor or maybe
not even your supervisor but somebody
one step ahead of you and say hey can i
buy you some cup of coffee like walk me
through your arc here when'd you start
here how'd you get to this role people
love to tell their story and you're
going to pick up a lot of wisdom along
the way about how your group operates
how the groups around you operate hang
on the line here and jenna will get your
information we'll send you a copy of
ken's book from paycheck to purpose that
just walks you through that process but
start thinking and dreaming big in the
meantime
keep your rent low yeah in the meantime
find it out manage your budget
and uh live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else in the meantime
you're gonna live in a place that you
don't want to live in for very long but
you'll live there for a little while
i did when i was your age i did too and
and it's not to say that it's mandatory
to do that but it's just to say that
there's no shame in that
i'm okay if you could live in a really
wonderful place because you were making
200 000 a year that wouldn't make me mad
at all either i'm not it doesn't it's
not required that you have hard times
but you are square in the middle of some
so you might as well get the getting
might as well get what's there to get
good for you and you're just a stud man
i'm unbelievable gosh
i'm
i'm not sure i could have dialed the
number
call this show no i was 19 the number of
19 year olds i've worked at that can't
figure out where the intramural office
is
good grief
trying to check out some ping-pong
paddles and i can't find the like oh my
gosh
and this guy's
having a second kid it's amazing
well it'll grow you up i can tell you
that it obviously is he's wise beyond
his you're a good young man you call us
anytime we can help hold on proud of you
jen i'll pick up and give you a copy of
coleman's book and we'll move you along
to the next next fantastic really cool
wow
wow
this is the day that i feel old the 19
year old this is the day huh
well shut up
i just caught up just today suddenly